[Music]
sup guys I'm Kim PhD here alright so as
far as tech people becoming billionaires
and then turning into philanthropists
for the greater good
Bill Gates pretty much the gold standard
as far as that goes
he's on pace to give away something like
ninety nine point nine six percent of
his wealth to charities and foundations
so for those wondering what he's doing
with host billions and billions of
dollars every year he and Melinda
dropped this annual letter where they
explain sort of their view of the world
at that time and what they're doing
about it so I'll leave the link to this
year's new 2019 annual letter below but
I got to actually go up and chat with
him in Seattle about this year I was
looking at it and this is that chat all
right mr. gates thank you for sitting
down with me for a couple minutes I'll
try to learn as much from you as
possible in our time super I think a lot
of my audience will know you from your
work at Microsoft a lot of tech heads
watching these videos but you've also
forged this entire I could call it a
second career as a philanthropist that I
think is equally as interesting and
impressive I'll try to tie those things
together first of all the annual letter
can you summarize the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation annual letter and like
a sentence or two
well Melinda and I get a chance to go
all over the world particularly in
Africa where a lot of our health work is
we go into a lot of classrooms where our
education work is and so every year we
try to think okay what would other
people be interested in in terms of new
innovations things that are going well
going poorly this year we framed it as
surprises right you know so I was
studying the population growth in
different countries and the age pyramid
in different countries and so you know
I'm finally seeing some good technology
used in the classroom to try and let the
teacher focus in on really talking the
students are not just grading the
homework so that was another one and it
is actually quite a diverse set of
things that
made our surprise list so one of the
things I read that I found really
interesting in it was you sort of broke
down the biggest contributors to
greenhouse emissions so manufacturing
agriculture transportation the
transportation one hit me because I'm
really into electric cars that's one of
the specific areas of tech focus on the
channel so I'm curious what's your take
on electric cars have you gone electric
how do you feel about well the you know
Tesla is an amazing product that is
catching on but it's still a pretty
small percentage of the market it's a
premium price Fiat going they lost their
$7,500 tax credit so it's making it
tougher now ton of the other
manufacturers are gonna come in partly
because the car California zero emission
and partly because people see these
trends there'll be a lot of really great
electric cars to choose from now will it
get down to the volume price categories
and then you know for transportation
it's not just automobiles we've got
trucks we've got you know trains boats
planes and so you know solving the
entire transport sector isn't gonna be
easy
you know transport is hard industrials
hard it's a wide range of innovations
we're gonna need and also I read that
especially in the US truck driver is an
extremely popular job in fact more than
half the US truck driving is like the
most popular profession in that state so
it sounds like electric might not be the
only solution to transportation
well the passenger car the power output
you need is lower them for a truck so
eventually batteries might work for a
truck but it's a far more difficult
problem because just the weight is a is
a lot higher there even those passenger
cars one thing to be careful of is
unless the electric sector has gotten to
zero the electric car is still an
emitter because of the indirect
emissions from the electricity it uses
right and so only in the place where you
both get the electric cars to be a hyper
centage and you get the electric sources
to be zero emission then you've got that
passenger transport car piece near
getting near to zero that's the goal the
AIA conversation
seems like a big it's kind of hard to
ignore it in 2019 and I've had
conversations other people who are more
a negative about it more pessimistic
about just AI and the the possible
downside I'm curious if you're more
optimistic about the upside of AI or
uses for it or ways to possibly make an
impact and and what you're trying to do
well the AI is allowing us to make
advances in fields that are are really
important like understanding the biology
of the human body it's super complicated
and so if you look at all the data you
gather because the sensors are getting
better you know trying to understand
okay how do we help people with obesity
how do we take cancer where is the point
wanna interfere even the one that's
really difficult is the brain is so
complicated that we don't have drugs for
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's and so we
want it not just people live longer but
them to live really quality years and
not have the medical cost be expanding
that's an area AI people feel like yeah
I'm not I'm not against that so see it
definitely has a lot of upside as far as
helping to to research certain things
helping to find patterns that a human
necessarily wouldn't have picked up
things like that so in medical fields
it's useful so I agree with you on that
I'm really happy about that if you could
give a couple short bits of good news
some good progress you've observed that
some people might not know about to sort
of counteract the bad news everyone
seems to hear about what would you say
yeah
the we used to have 10% of all children
born would die before they reached five
years old that number is now 5% and with
the right and innovations we can get it
by 2030 to two and a half percent so
we've gone from 12 million were dying to
now 6 million and so it's every year six
million live
saved all these things are tricky
because you don't want to say to people
that we we shouldn't be mad about the
remaining problem so say to people hey
feel good about the progress and still
you know be mad that that six million
are still buying
that's an interesting dichotomy it's a
it's a good perspective to have because
you have to you have to be proud of the
progress that's been made but you still
have to look forward at all the work yet
to be done and that's kind of I guess
what I'm wondering is my next question
is you've put billions of dollars in
over a decade into the Foundation's work
on these issues does it make you
optimistic about the future that that so
much progress has been done or do you
look at the challenges ahead and that's
like an overwhelming sort of massive
amount of work in a broad way the work
has gone so well on global health better
than we expected yeah and the innovation
and science that will give us new tools
like an HIV vaccine and a malaria
vaccine you know so in my lifetime I
hope the whole issue of these diseases
that are caught in poor countries mostly
infectious diseases we essentially solve
those problems and we're close on on
polio eradication when I look at
politics I have to admit they you know
there's some trends in terms of how what
trust people have or how they're
polarized I do worry about that that's
not you know a deep area I I don't bring
unlike the biology where I get to study
it and see it you know I'm on the same
footing as everybody and seeing these
political trends but yes there are
things that I I do worry about but
overall the human condition our ability
to feed prevent disease help people live
an enjoyable life we are making great
progress on those things so as long as
we stay committed to them you know that
it makes me love the work and and remain
optimistic all right well I hope
obviously your work goes as far towards
those successes as possible and I guess
my last question would be knowing that
you're doing all this work but so in my
position on
a philanthropist I don't necessarily
have the means how does someone like me
or someone watching this help in the
best way they can well I wish more
people could actually get to these
countries you know join the Peace Corps
spend time even just spending a few
weeks there and see how great the needs
are and see the progress a lot of you
know volunteer work and the United
States builds that sense of okay we care
about other humans even you know beyond
our own family group even people have
very different experiences so you know
at a young age a little bit of giving
money away you know to form that habit
and picking which things you really want
to give to including lots of things here
in the US and getting involved with
volunteer time those are the people who
I think will help kind of bring the
world together and you know avoid just
this divisive mess that is my greatest
concern I couldn't end a Bill Gates
interview without asking can you still
jump over a chair that's a good question
probably not and it would if it was a
very small chair
I'll count that as a victory that's a
victory you know I used to be able even
jump over a garbage can but I'm afraid I
do I play tennis so I'm in reasonable
shape but not my jumping skills that's
all good I appreciate it thanks again
for the thanks for coming out yeah I
appreciate it great to me too if we get
to do it again